Brandon Devine is a New York Post
columnist and really the world's
Authority on Hunter Biden's laptop
author of laptop from hell she joins us
with a reaction to all of this Miranda
you've been on parts of the story for
years now what do you make of this
well it's it just looks like projection
from uh Joe Biden doesn't it as usual
it's the Democrats tool of trade to
accuse their opponents of the very sins
that they are committing it's a little
obvious in this case now and you just
wonder uh why it's come out and really
what the true story is about these
confidential documents but as far as the
University of Pennsylvania goes there's
a long incestuous symbiotic relationship
with the bidens Joe Biden uh you know
you've got his grandchildren in there he
got the children of friends in there he
treated it as his own little playpen and
of course when he stepped down from
being vice president he was paid almost
a million dollars by the University of
Pennsylvania he put his name on that
supposed Think Tank
um and uh in return I suppose he his
name attracted a lot of China Chinese
money as you just said there was uh you
know the amount of money that came in
from China to the university after Joe
Biden opened that Think Tank uh
quadrupled almost quadrupled it went
from about 20 million to over 70 almost
75 million so
um that you you have to look at a quid
pro quo there and then you talk about
Naomi Biden Joe Biden's granddaughter
the oldest daughter of Hunter Biden and
just this very casual offer from a pen
professor of this
propaganda tour sponsored and paid for
by the Chinese Communist party with
business class tickets and she asked
Hunter what he thought he said go for it
and ask for two tickets so you can bring
your boyfriend it's Apprentice grifter
ship
it's it's just beyond belief and
happening out in public
but of course you know that because
you've been dealing with this for years
main advantage in New York Post we
appreciate it thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight